في بعض الأماكن يقولون إنه كافيار
إلى كافيار المكسيك
ليس من السمكة إذا لم يكن من النمل
من escamoles في بيضة
النملة لذيذة جدا
[موسيقى]
اسمي جوزي باريير آيلاندز
أكرس نفسي لهذا المجال
اثنين
عمري يزيد عن 40 سنة وأنا الآن
مجالات
[موسيقى]
في الموسم بين مارس وأبريل
إنه عندما يكون في موسم الهروب
عندما تتفتح الجريللا بالفعل
لها زهرة صفراء عندما تبدأ
الخطوة
[موسيقى]
البحث عنهم للعثور عليهم يكلف الكثير
خدشهم
هناك أوقات يقوم فيها بالخدش لعدة ساعات
يجدهم المرء
[موسيقى]
في بعض الأحيان عليك أن تخدش مترًا هناك
هذا الخدش بطول 23 مترا غير معروف
بالضبط أين أنت في
nyt ولكن بشكل جيد دعونا نفعل ما في وسعنا
للعثور عليه
عليك أن تكون في عجلة من أمره لإخراجه لأن
أكثر وأكثر أذهب للنوم و
يعضون لا تحركات صغيرة
أنه في بعض الأحيان لا تحصل على فكرة جيدة ولكن
نحن حمقى للحصول عليه
ما نريده لأن هنا تقريبًا كل ملفات
نحن حقا لا نعرف المدينة كثيرا
الناس الذين يعرفونه أكثر من أي شيء آخر
المطاعم الأكثر شهرة فيها
انها مثلي
الحشرات موجودة منذ زمن طويل
وقت طويل هو واحد من
المكونات الغذائية الرئيسية
ما قبل التاريخ
[موسيقى]
أنا جوزيفينا لوبيز مينديز وأنا
الشيف التنفيذي لمطعم تشابولين
تشابولين هو حقا مطعم
تحية لجميع المكونات
من المطبخ المكسيكي الذي يعمل دائمًا من
يد المنتجات والمنتجين
المكسيكيين وإعطاء الكثير من التركيز على
منتجنا المكسيكي لجميع
جمهورية
حسنًا ، هو مثل عندما تأكله
حسنًا ، طعمها حقًا مثل الزبدة
طعمه مثل الماء طعمه نبيل جدا
قاتمة جدًا عندما يمكنك عض أ
مسح كل ما هو حقا مثل كسر
إنه بالون وبعد ذلك به ماء
في الداخل كما هو الحال مع قطع صغيرة هناك اعتبارًا من
الجماعية
لا ، نحن عادة نطهوها
الابازوت والبصل ، وهو يخنة لذيذة جدا
كلاسيكي في كل المكسيك نرافقه
مع الجواكامولي مع الخبز المحمص وغيره مع
ذرة صفراء وقليل من الجبن
الأغنام ثم المسح هو كل شيء كيف
تعامل مع القليل من النكهات
قوية ولكن دائما تحترم النكهة
هذا مائي وزبداني عليك
له المقياس
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، ما زلت أعرف جدي
لكن فرحة مقابلته
كان أول من جاء إلى هذه المدينة
لتظهر لهم الخطوة وبعد ذلك أنا
أعطت جدي في أبي واستمر في ذلك
هذا التقليد
يقول إنهم غير قادرين على جدي
أنا أحب ذلك جيدًا ، فلماذا لا لأنني لن أفعل ذلك
مواصلة هذا التقليد من الاستمرار في اتخاذ
[موسيقى]
وحفيدي الآن أتمنى ذلك
كما تعلم مني حتى يكون هذا
اتبع العائلة وإذا كنت تتبع
العمر ما لم نفقد هو ذلك
تقليد لدينا
[موسيقى]